okay Chris Stockman with Blake Kennedy
or grounded for life
27 hey that's always sounds in real life
all the time
it's called personality like a
rhinoceros
so sometimes immediately what I want to
tell you is I just saw mr. Brooks oh yes
and that's I believe you said that was
like one of your favorite movies now it
is I don't get it I really didn't expect
you okay I mean it was okay but I mean
like favorite movies ever it's my number
30 in my top 30 of the same
constellation okay so it was like it
wasn't a 30 before we made it a top 30
just to include that in truthfully yes I
add in other movies in there just to
make room no it's talked 20 I'm actually
I had to talk 20 I'm like you know what
it doesn't seem like my 20th favorite
movie 25 that sounds better
I mean okay I really liked Kevin Costner
I thought he was great
William Hurt was okay oh gosh I mean I I
just I felt like he talked really fast
to me more with nothing special to me I
mean I didn't think her part was
terribly I mean it was necessary to
propel the plot but I didn't think she
was that great
Dane Cook annoyed the crap out of me but
I think you're kind of supposed to think
he's a giant d-bag but um okay just
there be spoilers for mr. Brooks in case
oh thank you yes I mean I think which
made the ending scene considerably more
uh uh excuse me my god
his characters annoyance and dbadgery
made the ending scene considerably more
satisfying though I can say it begs that
Dane Cook's character later that I like
and some what do you think about his
character you know like what he wants to
do and stuff it's like just like think
about like how little of a life he has
he spends his time you know watching his
neighbors having sex through the window
and he takes pictures of it yeah he's
just looking for like something exciting
to happen and he sees you know people
get killed these like I'm kind of my
Adrenaline's kind of flowing this is
cool this wants to do it and then when
his character I don't know every time
his character was on screen also he's
just so annoying I think it was acting
was very good and so I loved my favorite
part in the whole movie is actually the
at the end when you see a close-up of
Costner of his eyes open and then I mean
closed and the Dane Cook clicks the
barrel and Costner kindest jumps for a
second and then he opens her with his
eyes slowly and gets like this little
smirk I love that part and I also like
um he has like just literally a
one-second moment of hesitation before
smacking being cook in the head with the
shovel like he just he like wheels back
looks to the left for a second things
like I'm doing and they just hit some I
was like that's cool he has that he has
that one-liner before he before he hits
him in the leg with a shovel he's like
talks about like those file where the
pictures would be kept he's like it's
been removed or something
whacks him around the lake yeah yeah it
was just like yeah that helped me it was
pretty pathetic he was like I don't know
it didn't seem that great scream is
acting the scream the movie okay my
honestly my biggest problem with it was
the direction you like the direction it
was very it was like a music video man I
mean like what the heck was with that
scene where I know what scene you're
referring to before you this is okay
what look the Demi Moore shootout saying
yes yeah it's it was really weird I
don't know dude yeah character like I
love the film to death but that
character that she was shooting at I
failed to find how it was necessary in
any way yeah exactly
he came out all the lights gets shot out
and then all of a sudden there's this
like a strobe light and like some dance
song like it was like I don't know I
want to show you something girlfriend it
was if you want to know why I like the
movie so much it really affected me like
in a chilling sense to where when Kevin
um his character is not killing people
you know it seems like just like this
normal mentally stable nice guy it's
like Becky it's like even verging on a
likable character I don't know about you
yeah yeah what's that care for the guy
and then he has this addiction to
killing which he doesn't like and I um I
found that to be effective I I don't you
um state some complaints over his
performance I loved the interaction
between um Costner and her I thought
they had really good chemistry
I like how ya say like he's like this
normal healthy guy but you know because
this part of his brain was just you know
William Hurt you know wants to kill and
all that crap and I like one of the
subplots how they all tied in together
if my split personality was William Hurt
I don't know about you cuz this line in
the lost world I mean there's a lost in
space when that was obviously supposed
to be hugely dramatic but failed the end
where he's talking to like Matthew
LeBlanc for Joey from friends and that
the whole place is blowing up their in
their ship and they're like he's like
what do we do captain
and William Hurt just like pauses and
he's like we go through the planets we
go through the car we take the ship
through the planet I was like that's
terrible acting right there man
don't watch that movie dude
unfortunately I grew up watching it but
um I do actually really like William
Hurt though it's a very good actor yeah
yeah but um let me see yeah I just
thought the direction was crappy and I
also hated the it was all a dream ending
thing you know what I'm talking about
just that one scene was a dream I think
yeah but I mean it was I mean at the end
he like walks in on his daughter and she
stabs him in the neck but you don't you
know the meaning behind that though well
yeah I mean he's always an okay he
taught me talked about you know concerns
earlier in the film about his daughter
killing him yeah he's afraid she's gonna
become like him yeah and I just thought
I actually thought that ending was
rather clever yeah lightly yeah you know
it's it's debatable even to me if that
ending would be better but I like I
think that the ending itself that's the
ending they used I mean is okay
considering you know what I just said I
mean I like the fact that is you stop
doing that I'm sorry I was drinking
Cherry Coke and while I do this yes yes
viewers we're gonna this entire podcast
burping and talking about mr. Brooks no
it's just that um I feel the same way
like I liked the character which is
disturbing because of how messed up he
is but I was in class glad he was alive
at the end but I just thought the whole
dream thing was dumb also you're gonna
get mad at me for something else to what
I I haven't finished it yet but I'm
currently in the middle of Garden State
oh my god dude seriously you can't hate
on Garden State no one can do that you
like it's one of those things that I'm
personally
doom it's like burning a Bible or
something d'arnot States just like like
the most likable adorable cutest little
movie ever and like hating odds just
like kicking a puppy off a bridge I
haven't even said anything yet yeah but
you said you were I was gonna hate you
for it so it's not like they're gonna be
like I really love it so far if you did
love I don't like it but I don't hate it
or anything yet I mean it's not over I'm
halfway through it got considerably
better when Natalie Portman's character
is introduced I hate you no seriously
Natalie Portman is like the glue that
holds that movie together Peter
Sarsgaard bro what all the performance
of Emma we are great brats like a dude
he just sits there man
dude Peter Sarsgaard some of the
greatest actors ever I think he's cool I
suspect as soon as he came up on screen
I was like oh Peter SARS guards in this
awesome but he doesn't really do
anything I mean just kind of sits there
cuz he plays a STONER Chris what's
entertaining about sitting there
watching a STONER
well he's plenty of character and stoke
the stoners just sit there I guess they
do and dig graves
well characters a gravedigger oh yes he
did okay well we'll head over there when
we're done burying your mom yeah great
wine yeah I just some of the humor I can
tell they're trying to be funny but it's
not making me laugh the only thing I can
say bad about the movies that there's
too many physical comedy
gags involving dogs that's all I can say
my gosh I know every single dog walks
after my husband yeah but you know
taking the balls greatest movie ever
though it's your number four right it's
one over five I believe okay let me
check mr. Brooks is my 25
it's funny how and what they after you
watch it again I guarantee it I've
already I watch mr. Brooks three times
that I got it from Netflix watch
yourself yeah go on the state's my
number five
I will admit when I'm wrong but here's
the thing like I've noticed with some
younger film critics oh okay we're
generalizing now but a lot of people
I'm not generalizing I'm just saying
I've noticed a lot of times that people
state an opinion on a film the first
time they see it and like after they see
it a few times like yeah I kind of
overhyped it there's there shouldn't be
some movies know where that basically
happens to everyone like Avatar everyone
when they first saw avatar
they were like pooping their pants
they're like this is the greatest thing
ever and then they watch it again and
they're like what the heck that's true I
don't I feel my friends were and they're
younger but I mean I liked it a lot like
I you know honestly I guess I was I did
do that a little bit in 2009 I guess
that it was my favorite movie of the
year but at the time though I hadn't
seen so many movies that came out though
so it was like my only choice but I know
now I like state of play which is like
my number two or three more than that
yeah I'm towards my original number
three I think I'm moving to like eight
or ten or something like when I
originally saw it I gave it like a 10
and like this more I thought about it I
saw the second coming it might be like
an eighth now even a half I don't even
know I mean it's a really good movie but
just like actually this is my room the
first thing I thought the very first
time I saw the movie like I knew that
the human scenes just were not as
entertaining as the a precisely okay I
guarantee a second time I see this I'm
gonna be bored out of my mind or they're
not in the Avatar world and I was right
but you know it's this thing is like a
really like big diss on the film like I
want to say alright it's like I think of
it like more as a ride than a movie like
to see it in the theater like for like
DVD at home quality I can't leap icture
myself watching it I'm like really like
just for something to watch that's true
I'm just like an X here yeah cuz James
Cameron made the movie like to
revolutionize 3d so if you're like not
watching it a 3d on like a gigantic
screen
I saw it and I advised like you're not
really like like I don't know we're not
really getting what the movies doing I
guess Lydell I can't really not a phrase
lab but I don't know it's not really a
movie made to like watch that whole
one-year tiny TV example earlier I was
doing something on the computer and I
was like I just want to have some random
movie on the background I put on
Kindergarten Cop I would never just put
on Avatar such a dish I know it's weird
but I think a lot of James Karen with
Cameron movies are like that like you
guys are just you must watch them you
can't like just have it there like
that's a that's a good thing and a bad
thing at the same time except that
striptease scene in True Lies oh not
realize yet nah man it's not really on
the top of my list I don't get too
excited oh wow I don't even really like
it that much
yeah you were telling me that like is
the worst you were a pervert or
something
it's definitely James Cameron's worst
movie besides piranhas - you know what
movie came out this year that like
absolutely nobody saw it got like no
release at all but it has like a great
cast and I just came in my Netflix
yesterday and I'm probably gonna watch
it tonight I mean 10 but what did I say
he said this here oh yes this is 2011
it's an okay 2010 stone with Bravo
Robert De Niro Edward Norton and
amiability Julia you have it safely
Jovovich you know pitch she's hot thank
you thank you Chris
oh I just had the rain emerges a nice
long it's gonna confuse so many people
everyone just knows the plague is
slightly handicapped I'll work out